LOUIS GRAY: Hi.
I'm Louis Gray with Google
Developers Live, and welcome
to the second edition of Google
Developers Weekly-- our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world of
Google Developers on
the set and off.
Last week we kicked off this
show, keeping you on top of
all of the events in our
studios worldwide.
Let's go to the tape and see
this week's highlights, and
preview the week to come.
Google Drive and Google+ Photos
have always been good
friends, but it's now time to
take that relationship to a
brand new level.
Ali Ashar took to the studio
to show us how photos in
Google Drive are now
integrated with
your Google+ account.
Also in the world of Google+,
Joanna Smith invited product
managers Tor and Joelle to
discuss the launch of the
Google+ domain's API, enabling
companies and enterprises to
develop tools for
their businesses
on the Google+ platform.
Every single week, our team
from Tel Aviv takes a deep
dive into the world of APIs or
host experts from the world of
web and mobile.
This Wednesday, Ido Green showed
how you can leverage
the power of NodeJS on Google
Compute Engine to pull
information from the Yahoo
Finance API, and work with
that data in Google Docs.
This is just another cool
example of how open standards
can help different company
systems work together.
Back here in Mountain View,
Jeremy Walker of the YouTube
team invited guest Vidyard
into the studio.
If you create content on
YouTube, Vidyard can help you
turn your video content into
powerful marketing tools.
And after all, don't
engineers and
developers always love marketing?
The week in the studio wrapped
with the latest entry in our
Root Access series of growing
your start up and navigating
the world of venture capital.
Don Dodge and Martin Omander
updated us on the biggest
trends from two of the hottest
incubators at Silicon Valley--
500 Startups and Y Combinator.
Also, this next week promises
to be huge.
Brian Fitzpatrick, better
known as "Fitz," will be
taking on three big
topics on GDL.
First, organizational
manipulation.
Then data liberation.
And finally, Google's
Transparency Report.
I'll be fully transparent
with you.
I'm looking forward to asking
him the tough questions on
business politics, and just how
I can get all my data out
of Google if I want to.
Here on GDL, we may not have
Shark Week, but we
do have Fitz week.
Outside of the studio, Google
Analytics' Nick Mihailovski
introduced a new analytics
metadata API.
Now you can find out which API
and which metrics can be
queried from Google Analytics
core reporting.
Check out our Google Developers
blog for more details.
On our Google+ page, we shared
a post about the new Dart
Editor, which adds new
features and fixes.
The flashiest features, you
can now inspect classes in
running apps.
Find out more at
dartling.org/editor.
To make sure you never miss a
thing from the world of Google
Developers, subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube,
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.